[Music]
our series of more perfect union aims
and i think succeeds at showing what
unites us as americans is far greater
than what divides us now as the country
struggles to fight systemic racial
injustice many parents
are searching for ways to discuss
diversity and privilege with young
children well this morning we meet
oakland california's alphabet rockers a
hip-hop group for children and families
and our jamie yukas
has been following their journey since
before the pandemic
she shows us how they're standing up to
racism
and breaking down barriers
just because you say we need equality
too e is for equality if you don't look
like
me will you stay on my back and what
you're hearing is no illusion
the alphabet rockers rap about inclusion
[Music]
these 11 and 12 year olds contribute to
the lyrics hoping to inspire kids to
wake up
and stand up for others
[Music]
do you think you can change the world
yes most definitely
you do yeah it's a new generation
like things change
the group was founded by caitlin mcgawe
and tommy celotti shepard
who teamed up to tackle discrimination
there's no words to describe
what our country will turn into if we
don't turn it around
[Music]
we first met the kids earlier this year
in a recording studio
after their album earned them a second
grammy nomination
now covet forced them to take their
message online
people get judged for who they are most
adults
think that we're supposed to just sit
back and be
cute and smile but we have powerful
ideas and we can use those
to create a better world
they've created an anti-racism course
for families in the hope of sparking
conversations about equity empathy and
race
for folks who haven't been engaging in
this conversation
it might be a little harder but it's
definitely necessary
that's my word right even if i'm sure
i'm a beautiful girl
why is it important for you to teach
other kids to stand up to racism
i think it's important because there's
so much of it in the world right now
this generation has no choice but to
stand up
as protesters filled the streets
demanding social justice
the young rockers joined in and marched
too we just want to be
treated like human beings and not get
killed and have not have our people
killed
is that too much to ask like i feel like
it's really not
what do you think about if people were
watching this and they say to themselves
wow this is just
this is way too much to put on a 12 year
old i think it's good for kids to stand
up for social justice because
we're gonna be the next adult
all have stories of racism at school
there was a lot of teachers this year
that like targeted
the brown and black kids and gave them
worse punishments yelled at them a lot
more
racism is the reason why i've gotten
teased about my skin color and gotten
told things
such as you're too dark to play with us
another layer for the alphabet rockers
making the world safer for lgbtq youth
studies show suicidal thoughts in
transgender youth
decrease by 34 percent when their
preferred name
and pronoun are used
[Music]
eleven-year-old heiress who performs
with the group is gender fluid
what pronouns do you use i use they them
pronouns
do people ask a lot of questions
sometimes they want me to explain a lot
my gender is always changing so this
whole thing allowed you
to feel more like yourself i think so
yeah
it's music with a message making the
world better
one beat at a time hear our voices join
our action
we're leading with luck you coming if i
learned it early then it'll be easier
when i become an adult
because i don't want to be a bad adult
for cbs this morning jamie yukis los
angeles
uh tommy just asked the best question
you coming yeah yeah we're coming tommy
beautifully done jamie you guys love
what he said
awesome